và ai sao bằng ngày rõ mắt, lại thôi từ lại rương và người.
Một cái đại đợi là nhiệt dù biết,
như dù biết là nhiệt lợi,
cần thiệt để cho mưa,
khi nó găm chất nó,
tăng đến một đủ xe.
Chất nào mà có nhiệt dù biết,
cảm lơn,
phí chất nó,
cảm khó tăng nhật nổ.
Thành ở nợi,
chất nào mà có nhiệt dù biết như họ,
phí nó tăng nhật nổ sẽ nhàng hơi,
thì bây mà chái đất và mặt miệnh,
nhất nhất nừa từ lại sáng mặt chời.
Bất kia biết rồi,
trên mình mặt nất,
thì nhất nướng rương của đất chỉ có tám chăm.
Nhưng mình nhất nướng của nước,
ở trên đây mặt của bây hả,
thì muốn nhìn thái chăm,
người thì trên mình mặt chái đất này,
nó sẽ tăng nhật nổ nhàng hơi nước nổ,
sau với trên bây màn miệnh.
Em mẹ là,
trên bây màm chái đất dài khi mà nữa nhẹ được dịch,
thì nó tăng nhật độ này,
nó tăng nhật độ này nhàng.
Nó tăng nhật độ này nhàng thì làm cho các phân cử khí chuyện đọc nhàng hơi.
Em học rồi,
các phân cử khí chuyện đọc nhàng hơi,
phí làm cho mặt bộ phân cử khí nó,
nó loang hả,
nóng hả,
lúc này,
chế vừng không khí ở trên bây màn,
đất này nó sẽ có ám xuất thấp,
ám xuất thấp,
em yêu gia,
lộn,
trên bây màn miệnh,
thì ra yệt vung li của nó nữa,
ra ra cho lý ra,
thì vùng không khí ở phía trên bây màn,
như biển này,
nó có ám xuất,
câu hư,
ám xuất cau hư,
như vậy trên này có ám xuất cau.
Mày em biết rồi,
ra,
thì được khinh thành nhờ không khí rịch chuyện,
thì nó có ám xuất cau,
sáng được cả xuất thấp,
như vậy,
lựng này sẽ hình thành lên ró,
ra chính là không khí rịch,
thì mình thử nơi có ám xuất cau rịch chuyện,
và nơi có ám xuất thấp,
như vậy,
nước này,
gió sẽ từ biển phổ thảo,
đất lên.